When I skate,
I feel like I’m flying on the ice
and it feels really good.
This Great Big Story was made possible
by Lego: Play Her Way.
My name is Young Yoo.
I’m 15 years old
and I’m a figure skater
who represents South Korea.
I was 6 years old
when I started figure skating.
The first time I was on the ice,
it was really hard to just stand
and just skate,
so I fell a lot
but it was still really fun.
Young Yoo is a 3-time South Korean
national figure skating champion.
She was just 11 years old when she won
the title for the first time,
making her the youngest in history.
She also qualified
for the Winter Olympics in 2018.
When I was 14,
I qualified for the Olympics,
but I was too young to compete
in the Olympics – sadly!
Young Yoo has
a rigorous training schedule,
which has her travelling the globe.
I train in Colorado and Japan and Korea.
I’m now working on my triple axel.
Triple axel is spinning in the air
for 3.5 rotations.
That is the hardest jump in the triples.
After that I’m working on
my quad salchow with the harness.
The quad salchow is turning in the air
four rotation,
so it’s the hardest jump that I’m doing.
Being a figure skating champion
is hard work,
but Young Yoo is motivated
by the support of her family.
Sometimes I’m not as good as usual,
but my mom supports me and gives love,
so it helps me,
and all my family cheer me up.
It makes me do more hard work.
[ANNOUNCER] Please welcome now
from the Korean Skating union;
Young Yoo!
In the competition,
when the music comes,
my heart is bouncing
like it’s going to burst,
and it feels like I’m flying.